this team of researchers asked the
biographers the really top biographers
for all the presidents from the from the
beginning all the way through almost up
to the President and said rate them on
this second psychopathic scale than they
did right at the top was Teddy Roosevelt
then FDR then JFK Bill Clinton was right
up there a people really low on the way
low in psych psychopathy like Jimmy
Carter Gerald Ford a George Bush Senior
the very low psychopathy George but the
Sun is kind of in the middle up so
anyway there's this group that are very
high group low the thing is is that if
you look at what people consider
leadership Who am I going to follow they
pick the people at the top they're
picking in voting for and enjoying that
the psychopathic traits because those
are the people that you think are are
the ones who can lead you and in fact
these are you know Psychopaths cup notes
really being world champ Liars
pathological liars even for the hell of
it right and so if you look at people at
the top of the presidential list they
did in fact lie but the thing is they
lied for us they lied to protect us and
people for some reason don't seem to
mind psychopathic behavior when it's
done on their behalf it's like the
person who wants to get the best deal
they want they want the money manager
that's gonna if they're gonna cheat
cheat for me make me money if you're
going to lie lie and save me
let's save us and so a lot of the
behavior of leaders like that who have
these are such that people will say they
don't like it but they vote for it over
and over and over again so it must be
something very essential in us they're
not thinking I want to vote for a
psychopath but they like those traits
and those traits are strongly associated
with the psychopathy you would also
think people would say well you know
Hitler and all those Nazi leaders must
have been Psychopaths and yet the
analysis by many many psychiatrists over
the years a Hitler does not come up as a
psychopath and none of those Nazis do at
all they're all family men they're all
um very liberal very smart and they
thought they were doing their job and
that's why I Hannah Aaron you know when
she talked about this she didn't call it
psychopathy the way she analyzed it is
that people will get into a position and
they're just little pieces of a bigger
organization the organization is evil
right
it's the banality of evil is what she
called it but each individual's role is
sort of hidden and so people with those
tendencies can be not fully psychopathic
but they will do things that within an
organization will get them what they
want so they they help to launch and
it's a fulcrum for general psychopathy
let's say in a culture country so that's
a little bit different but the
individual ones that there's a study
that just came out on mafia and Sicily
so they took in prison mafia now these
were not that very top guys but that was
the kind of the middle management of the
mafia and all of them tested lower and
psychopathy than the average person know
psychopathy but you would think that
Nazis mafia psychopathy it's not see if
there's kind of a misunderstanding of
what it is and there are really very few
psychopathic killers and there's very
few of the ones you would see in a film
or TV they're extremely rare people but
they are working with you and they you
know in any organization that has more
than about 35 people but you're just
going to be somebody in there it's
really a psychopath but they're put
themselves there and they're usually in
a spot where they can lord it over
people just below them and get what they
want
and use a manipulation and some
intimidation and they can use it to get
sex they can use it to get money to
manipulate steal whatever it is or just
to create a world that they own and that
would be another part of this there are
there's a kind of psychopathy that
they're not getting anything for it's
not there's no sex drugs money or
anything like that but they are creating
a world that they bring you into and
they control you but most of them don't
do any of these these really fully
criminal nasty violent things at all
because they don't wanna go to jail they
don't really caught they like their life
they really like the
you